welcome back to the release podcast in
the dunya the three muslims we're joined
here once again with brother musa adnan
who just dipped for probably internet
reasons
salaam alaikum anna what's going on bro
[Music]
everything's good
for having me on again guys may allah
bless you
for a lot of people that aren't aware we
already had one episode with you
mashallah it was just me and rami
brother angel couldn't make it that day
so it's only right that this time on uh
made it but rami couldn't make it so
inshallah next time bro i got a dip so
it's only going to be all three
but aside from that bro what's going on
in the uk
alhamdulillah things are good in the uk
uh we just done
the hotbar a few a few hours ago
so
i'm just here in one of the centers we
have here alhamdulillah
and yeah man is so chilled alhamdulillah
we're taking it easy
what was the hobo about
i've done the khutban change
so
a lot of people they have the mentality
that
um
you know i'm an adult now i can't change
this is just how i am
and i basically spoke about
change from an islamic perspective that
no you can change and that's
basically a false idea that's being
spread by people
yeah man
okay
bro random question but what are like
give me like one or a couple of like the
the top most influential speakers for
you
in the dawah those that have helped you
and i know like we want to give a
pre-phase disclaimer right now anyone
you don't mention it doesn't mean that
they didn't help you it's just
particularly noteworthy individuals that
come to mind right now
uh for me personally aside aside from
the three muslims obviously bro
for me personally um online
um i really benefit from um there's a
sheikh his name his
his stuff is very good but his stuff is
in arabic but for me that's my favorite
person online if i was to give one
person online who's stuff i really
benefit from his stuff is amazing if you
understand arabic his stuff is really
really good in the english speaking
language one shaykh that i really like
his talks have really benefited me in
the past
is sheikh abu usam
i don't know if you guys have heard of
him
he's he's american actually he's
american originally um he
he gives a lot of talks here in the uk
and especially online you can find a lot
of stuff online a very very good man
very very good he's a very passionate
speaker he's a very good speaker
and
i i really like his his stuff as well
bless them and continue to preserve them
i mean
so the topic of today everyone's already
seeing the the topic it's not clickbait
this is genuinely today's episode it's
going to be on just isms bro just
different ways of life different
ideologies today that muslims are are at
a fork in the road with sometimes with
their identity thinking should i take
from this is there benefit from this
should i take from that so my first
question to you is when it comes to
anything such as red pill feminism
anything that dictates gender dynamics
according to its own i guess way of life
or ideology
when did you first start coming across
these things such as red pill and et
cetera
the first time i came across redpool
was within the last year or so
to be honest with you and i think that's
when i mean for me personally that's
where i've seen it really blow up online
a lot of people talking about it a lot
of controversy okay i think you guys are
involved in some of that or something
right uh but like a lot of controversy
uh around it that's red pill i heard
about feminism
long time before red pill years ago
maybe like i think feminism has been
around for quite a while i don't know if
red pill has
but um i know feminism has been around
for quite a long time
um okay and what was your i know i know
exactly what you're talking about about
a year ago there were a couple brothers
that we know they were making videos
about red pill should muslims follow red
pill there were some debates so what was
your initial impression about red pill
as a muslim man
initially i'll be honest initially some
of the stuff that was being mentioned i
thought okay like i agree with this
stuff
you know um initially some of the stuff
that was being mentioned i thought to
myself some of this stuff
does seem to be in line with islam
that those were my initial thoughts
um
but i've i'm always skeptical man of
this type of stuff
that's coming up because
any ideology any any like philosophy
that is outside of islam
you know there's gonna be some dodgy
stuff man like there's gonna be
something that comes in
where you know um
it's it's it's gonna it's gonna be a bit
problematic like this is from my
experience like for example at one point
i was really into stoicism
you know stoic philosophy and i was like
man this stuff is amazing like you got
some of the ryan holiday books um i
bought them read them and i'm like man
this stuff is really good like the
obstacle is the way is one of the books
i read and i was like man it's a crazy
book but then you start seeing
certain things creeping in
one thing i noticed with stoicism for
example is
the constant mention of marcus aurelius
right
they're the roman emperor
so and he's like one of the founding
fathers they say of stoicism and whatnot
or like one of the main you know
marujits if you want to call it like
people who return back to him for it and
whatever and his book meditations so i
thought okay let me buy his book
meditations
i bought that
and that's some next level stuff i
remember like the first few pages i'm
reading you've got some shirky stuff in
there kofree stuff like some next level
things right that you are muslim you
don't want to read
okay
um and i kind of felt like okay i was
hooked in by these flashy
books and
really really nice nicely presented you
know ideas
but then when i'm hooked in i'm being
given some of this stuff that i didn't
ask for
and
how a lot of it is
yeah yeah
it's one of the things in um
[Music]
in stoicism
is that if you are
if you are sick
or like let's say you can't fight you
can't really do anything you're not of
use
then it's better to just
end your life
right just straight up just
see you see your way out
yeah and that's that's not something
that clicks with islam yeah yeah islam
one of the qasid one of the you know one
of the things that the sharia is here
for one of the things that islam is here
for is preserving life
it's actually the opposite of that it's
preserving life right so
yeah i mean and we'll get more into this
stuff obviously but yeah man that's
that's crazy
um subhanallah bro i can relate with you
on so many levels when i first came
across red pill stoicism a lot of these
ideologies it initially
gets you in because we had one of the
brothers uh his name's hamza on the
channel and what he mentioned on the
channel was he said that the red pill
only seems
jaw dropping to us because we lived in
such a blue pill world you know like we
lived in such a world where
uh gender relations and intersexual
dynamics was so backwards that if
there's a glimpse of truth even if it's
one percent in red pill it just seems so
like eye opening to us but when in
reality it's it's far from it that's the
thing so what helped you discern
that rp might not be 100 right
and there's a lot of elements that are
not in line with reality whatsoever
especially islam for you
first of all as muslims one of the
things that we need to understand is
and and this is
when when we hear these things these are
not cliche statements islam is perfect
what islam is giving you
is perfect and when you insinuate and
you infer
that i need something from this ideology
and i need something from that ideology
you are inferring without without
explicitly saying it you're inferring
islam lacks this
or
i could get this
because here's the thing
if if you if you work for a company
and the company is giving you every
single thing that you need
they're providing you a home a car
they're giving you a very good salary
they're giving you everything that you
need anything that you ask for they're
giving it to you and you acknowledge
yeah you guys are giving me everything
you guys have given me everything that i
need and then
after saying that you say
but i'm gonna go check this company over
there because you know and then someone
says to you why why are you going over
there for why why are you doing that for
and you say oh well
i just feel like you know i could
benefit from this as well
people are going to look at you strange
people are going to look at you strange
so similarly islam
you know allah subhanahu ta'ala has
completed islam the prophet muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam he was
perfect in his character any positive
characteristic that there is he
salallahu was the closest
to that characteristic and you see this
when you read his life and any negative
characteristic that there is he is the
furthest away from that characteristic
so so
personally when i see
movements like red pill etc yeah it's
true i mean you might find something in
there that agrees with islam and you
might find something in hinduism that
agrees with islam and you might find
something in christianity that agrees
with islam you might find you might you
may find someone who is a pedophile
saying something you know as one
statement comes out of his mouth where
you're like yeah okay that makes sense
right but does that mean now we take on
the ideology does that mean that we take
on you know these ideologies that in
reality
each each ideology
has a purpose
each being has a purpose so
you have to ask yourself the question
what is the
what is the end goal of this ideology
the end goal of islam what is the end
goal of islam what what do i want to get
out of islam islam
it fixes your current life it gives you
good in this dunya and
the end goal of islam is a person
becoming closer to allah a person
becoming a mutati a person eventually
entering jannah a person living the best
way that they can on this earth and
going into the best place that they can
in the afterlife
that
some things that a person may argue are
the end goals of islam what's the end
goal of red pill
for me to sleep around
what's the end goal of red pill for me
to be seen by women in a certain way
what's the end goal of red pill for okay
um the the you know the the promotion of
high value man and this is the thing
you know money right exactly and this is
the issue this is the issue brothers
when you talk about ideologies whether
it be red pure feminism etc
what are these ideologies based on
okay
as muslims the way that we look at a man
and we give value to a man we the way we
give value to a human being subhanallah
is very different it's it's inherently
fundamentally different from the way
others give value to things so for
example in in outside society what
things are valued if you have money
you have money you have a nice woman you
have wealth you have cars you have all
of these things you have social status
yes these are these are things that are
valued outside but from an islamic
perspective to allah whose opinion
matters
explicit
indeed you know the most noble of you
the ones who have you know the
essentially
who who is the best of us the most noble
of you are those
who are
you are those
who are the most conscious of allah
because from an islamic perspective
becoming conscious of allah
it saves you it it will it will affect
every single
aspect of your life it will affect the
way that you if you are muslim properly
it will affect the way you are with your
mother your wife your father the way you
are with people the way you speak the
way you act the way you behave the way
you dress every single the way you go to
the toilet
every single thing
that you do islam affects that and
similarly
islam has ideas about marriage and the
way a man should be and if you're taking
certain ideas and this is the fear some
people may say well i'm just taking the
good from red pill i'm just taking the
stuff that we agree with yeah but if
there's anything good in red pure if you
as a muslim say i'm taking the good from
red pill and you actually deep down
believe that islam doesn't have this
good that you're referring to
that's actually a very dangerous
statement
because you're insinuating
that
okay islam is incomplete if someone
believes that
we bet as muslims believe the prophet
sallallahu alaihi sallam came with
perfect goodness
and if you're if you if you're having to
go to other places
you're imperfect
you you're insinuating imperfection so i
actually you know i would like angel to
comment on this you know because you're
a river angkil how is islam
affected
the aspects of your life you know how
has it actually changed your life
i mean it's changed in every single way
and in regards to what you're saying
about like
finding wisdom and insight in other
places like listen i'll be the first one
to say
that i was all for that i was all for
like look like why not just take
take what works and then throw away the
rest from the other stuff you know and
then add it to your deen but it's like
the more the more that i
you know keep going on this path the
more that i
study islam and
you know
certain words that i can't they're not
coming to my head right now but the more
that i learn about it
the more that i see that like okay when
i find something outside of islam that i
find valuable
it's already in islam
it just means that i haven't i haven't
gone deep enough into islam into my
studies to have found it but it's there
so anytime that i see something that is
of value i always kind of like put it on
the side
nowadays i just put on the side like
okay that's really that's really nice
now where can i find that in islam
because i know it's in islam because if
i find it in islam well then it's
completely aligned with
being a muslim if i only use it from
so-and-so place well now i gotta
start taking what comes with that you
know what i'm saying
yeah yeah yeah yeah exactly exactly
and the thing with a lot of people and
this is the thing this is the case with
a lot of uh muslims unfortunately um
[Music]
we as a community are very lacking in
terms of education even islamic
education
so who told you that you you're even
gonna be able to discern the right from
the wrong
the good from the back
your your experiences as a human being
are limited
your knowledge is limited right and as
you go on in life you're going to
realize oh that thing i've done was
wrong this was right etc and whatnot so
how are you able to discern and this is
the thing this this doesn't mean
you know because there's extremism here
this doesn't mean
that
you know we're saying
that there's no good um you know in in
in for example if someone says something
right
if someone says the truth we accept the
truth if it comes from someone
but that doesn't mean that we now follow
and identify there's another thing you
identify by an ideology
that
is going to be inherently different to
islam you know so we have to be right
[Music]
because the extremist point bro that you
mentioned there's too much too much of
an extreme too much of a dichotomy
nowadays it's like anyone that's part of
the red pill they're like oh if you
don't agree then you're blue pill you
know if you're not alpha you're beta
like bro what does this even mean like
what this there's too many of these
these these binaries these false
binaries that you you add and to an
extent when i was
reading up on the red pill a few years
ago it's like it eventually leads to a
point where there's no morality anymore
and we talked about this on the channel
a lot before
it's it's almost promoting men to become
higher value at the expense of women
and then you look at feminism it's to
promote women's rights but at the
expense of men so none of them are
giving both of them inherent rights
without putting and belittling down the
other group
yeah
you know subhan allah
look at this here
there is a hadith is narrated by
al-bazar on the authority of jabir
he said okay listen to this
he copied part of the torah in arabic
okay
because brothers and sisters here's the
point we need to realize
that you know these things are different
ideologies different ways of looking at
things
do you think that this is just happening
in our time
this there were different ideologies and
ways of life at the time of the prophet
sallam at the very inception of islam
okay at the very inception of the sharia
when the prophet saw salaam was alive
there were other ideologies but look at
this now omar
he copied part of the torah in arabic
okay this is the torah
he brought it to the prophet sallallahu
alaihi and began to read it to him
as he read the prophet's face changed
color
the prophet's face changed color
okay one of the men of the ansar he said
woe to you ibn al-khattab can you not
see the face of the messenger of allah
thereupon the prophet
alaihi wasallam said do not ask the
people of the book about anything for
they will not guide you when they have
gone astray
you will either disbelieve in what is
right or believe in what is false by
allah if moses had been alive today he
would have been obliged to follow me
okay
okay now even though
okay there is um
you know there is some sort of there is
discussion on the
um authenticity of this hadith etc you
know one of the things that we need to
realize my dear brothers yeah is that
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
what did he tell us to do did the
prophet sallam instruct us to go okay
guys go to the you know this mentality
that's come oh we're going to get the
good from everywhere etc no no islam is
the good take islam you go in front of
you it's like if you've got diamonds in
front of you we can give so many
examples and i don't want to go on and
on and you know keep saying the same
thing but
if you've got diamonds in front of you
why on earth would you be going looking
for copper
and fishing out diamonds or trying to
find other you know gems from copper you
have islam islam is is from allah
subhanahu ta'ala you don't need this
stuff you actually don't need this stuff
subhanallah bro that's facts listen i
had one question for you before i asked
that let me just address the chat so
brother assad writes marshall
and rasheed looking young
about it bro uh we are brother maliki
click writing there are 73 people here
think of it this way you buy a five
dollar coffee daily one i support the
three muslim channel that's nothing on a
monthly basis joining up so shout out to
brother maliki we had him he's a he's a
reaver who found islam in prison we had
him on the show last week may allah
bless him
oh let's see
[Music]
90 plus people and only 51 legs come on
guys get those likes up in sha allah so
brother musa my question to you is
a lot of the time when you address
groups in society
that might identify with let's say
feminism or liberalism or the alphabet
gang
because you're in one extreme because
they're in one extreme by definition
everything else seems like it's on the
other extreme and mentioned this point
on a podcast even if you're in the
middle path in the center right between
all extremes
which is islam alhamdulillah it still by
default seems at another extreme because
they're on one extreme so when you say
anything even if it's with the most
other with the most respect with the
most empathy
it still automatically shuts off a lot
of people
so what's your solution to this because
i see a lot of youtubers nowadays
martial lamella preserve them and bless
them but
they come at it in a way where it just
gets his sisters to just shut off right
away or it gets the people that are not
on the straight path to just kind of
abort
yeah yeah yeah no subhanallah the way
you approach things is very very
important your approach is very very
important and you know
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
he
was conscious of who he was speaking to
and
what the people would think about him
what the people would think about him
so the reality is
we need to be conscious of
you know um how we're coming across the
people and i i assume you're you're
talking about you know advising people
you know whether it be about feminism
and ritual right
yeah inshallah just getting them to kind
of leave any of these ideologies fully
in terms of identifying and just coming
to islam
so here's the thing man like you can be
very very like
upfront about and stuff like that but
but the reality is your approach is very
very important because if you approach
yourself
in an extreme way or in a way that you
feel like is going to be perceived as
extreme they're not going to listen to
you no none of us is going to listen no
one no one is going to listen to anyone
who's coming to them and coming across
as extreme you're not going to listen to
that person
you're simply not going to listen to
that person and here's the thing as i
die
as someone who is calling to something
okay the way you come across to the
person who you're calling is of utmost
importance
that that is the thing so for example if
you're coming across rash and you're
speaking to sisters about leaving
feminism for example and you're coming
across really really extreme and you're
saying abusive things hurtful things etc
they're not going to listen to you
you're just discrediting yourself no
one's going to listen to you yeah and
and what you're doing is you're actually
discrediting your cause because your
cause is
you're trying to bring people to islam
and you want people to leave other
ideologies but then
while you're doing that you also need to
be conscious of those people's emotions
okay a lot of the time you know
a sister may for example
adopt the ideolo the ideology of
feminism because of experiences she's
gone through in her life
she may come from a culture that is
misogynistic
she may come from a culture that is
misogynistic and she's interpreted islam
to be misogynistic because she thought
her culture is islam
so now when you're talking to her
and you're speaking to in an abusive way
you're basically proving her right
you're proving her right and she's wrong
because islam is not like that but when
you're coming across as a muslim brother
etc in that way it's completely wrong
and that's the thing that's where you
need to be conscious of the way you're
coming across same thing same thing with
red pill
and we say to the brothers you know
masha'allah brothers you know you've got
some uh you're on to something or
whatever etc but instead of referencing
and he this is the reality here okay
you guys are going and you're referring
to a fajir
kafir
for your guidance on islam
someone who the way islam looks at him
this is a person who's rejected you know
the revelation etc
and
the way islam looks at this person
you're going to this person for advice
on essentially how to live your life but
it doesn't make sense right it actually
doesn't make sense so you need to make
people realize that but your approach is
very very important
you know
when when when you know
we read in the quran about pharaoh
he's one of the biggest criminals to
walk the face of this earth one of the
biggest
he said
in the quran
he claimed to be allah he said i'm your
lord the most high ana
he's a human being saying this
but what did allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
say to musa
and haroon
when he sent them
to go and speak to phil
very very interesting
regardless of this man being such a big
criminal
being an oppressive man an arrogant man
allah said
and say to him words
speak to him in a soft manner
speak to him in a manner that is laying
why so that he can you know so that
essentially he is able to take in what
you're saying so that you can
but but now imagine musalam and harun
they went to him and they aggressive
so so this is the point even and this
goes by the way this isn't just for red
pill and feminism
this goes for anything in your life you
know when you're speaking to your mother
your father you're trying to advise your
friend you're trying to advise people
have emotional intelligence a lot of
people they lack
serious emotional intelligence they
don't know you know how to come across
as people and this is problematic
so yeah man that's what i would say on
that
i don't know what you guys think
it's a lot to
it's about to unpack
i'm kind of like
my mind is like
just thinking about the whole stoicism
thing it's for a long time before i
became muslim like
i was real into the stoicism
yeah yeah
like
the meditations book yeah i read that
well some of it i should say i didn't
read the entire thing
yeah um
but man like something
that happened when i was like practicing
stoicism
was uh
getting to the point where i was
emotionless
you know
getting to the point where it's like
i didn't feel sad
i didn't feel happy i feel angry i was
just
stoked i was like a machine
and
while i that just made me feel empty
and there were times where i had to like
sit and ask myself like damn like is
this is this really it like
yeah like it helped me out in the
beginning but like the deeper i get into
this like the more i'm feeling like this
you know
and uh then when i came into islam
uh i started to see okay it's the middle
path you know you're never overly
emotional but you're never overly
unemotional
you're in that middle way right
and um i know this is like
this is taking a step back here in terms
of the conversation because
you had said one thing and i'm i'm
bringing it to something else
that we were already talking about i
just want to say that because it's been
on my mind for the past few minutes
um
yeah because the thing is bro like this
stuff changes lives man
like that's what people don't realize as
well when you get into like a different
ideology
and you invest yourself in it you read
on it you watch videos on it
it's gonna affect you like it's gonna
because you're watching it to take you
in
you're consuming it right
we become what we consume
um we become what we consume so when
you're consuming stoicism at times
initially you might feel very empowered
like yeah man this is the stuff like the
obstacle is the way and my problems you
know i know how to get through them now
and etc and whatnot then you realize
because here's the thing as a human
being
we want to feel fulfilled as human
beings we want to feel we want to feel
the void that we feel in our hearts
because we feel a void
and
for as long as time goes you know and
this shows you like you know
you can speak to these guys and you can
watch them on youtube these guys who are
partying
they were you know following every
single carnal desire that they had and
they were going to extremes in those
desires how it destroys you and then you
see movements coming up
that are encouraging people to stop
masturbation don't watch porn don't do
this don't do that yeah but from a
non-muslim perspective why shouldn't i
do that
no people should challenge it why
shouldn't i do that
if if me as a human being i have desires
and i want to do something and it's not
illegal why can't i do it for
why can't i do that
why can't i watch pornography why can't
i
you know be addicted to doing so i'm not
harming anyone etc but but this is the
thing
this is the thing and this is where when
you make life subjective
you know about what he thinks and what
she thinks etc and we all have limited
experiences we don't know where we're
going but when you
and and this is the value of islam that
we don't realize when you value islam
like angel you're talking about stoicism
and etc and how it made you feel at a
certain time islam is a way of life that
empowers you there are certain things
you're told that you can't do
but it gives you alternatives there are
certain things you know um you know you
may feel a certain way but just because
you feel a certain way doesn't mean that
you are you know you know subhanallah we
even learned that in islam
a person is not accountable for the
thoughts that cross their mind unless
they act upon them or unless they speak
about them etc right so even thoughts
that are crossing your mind you know you
have a source shaytan these thoughts are
from shaytan etc all of these things
you know subhanallah they change a
person's life and that's why if you're
going to choose something you need to
choose the right thing
you need to choose the right thing
it is man it comes back to
the fact that islam is perfect
you know and
look at the main reason why people go
into these other things
yeah
right they they want
they want guidance
they want role models but what better
place to get that than islam when islam
is perfect you have the perfect role
models you have the perfect guidance
you know and it's like
we're always looking we're always
looking for a role model let's be honest
even as a kid a kid is always looking
for that role model that they can begin
to emulate
well
i mean i don't know about y'all but
if i'm looking towards a role model i
look for
the best possible role model there is
right
yeah well i mean if you actually look up
on google the best man in the world in
existence
was the prophet muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam so why then would you
choose another role model besides that
you know what i'm saying like this is
where
if people just reflect on it
and they see it for what it is and
it just it all clicks it all makes sense
and then the deeper into islam you get
the more you start seeing ah okay
this thing that i was seeing here
it's in islam
but islam has even more than what this
thing was telling me exactly
exactly
um see the thing that brother musa said
about islam being perfect and complete
and suffice like sufficient you don't
get that with another ideology because
you might find glimpses of truth on like
marriage or or how to have a fulfilling
relationship with the kuffar in one
ideology but it might not talk about
finance it might not talk about you know
what happens when you are giving your uh
basically when you when you leave back
money for your for the deceased you know
islam is a comprehensive way of life it
doesn't leave any stone unturned
anything that we needed to know
right in terms of living a good life for
this life and for the akhirah it's
already in the quran and sunnah there's
nothing else that we need so to the
brothers that are you know and the
sisters obviously that are
caught in this fork in the road like
should i implement some things from here
some things from there it might
oftentimes just be an emotional issue
they might emotionally relate to
something that was said in one ideology
because of something in the upbringing
just like brother musa said or something
that they see in society being lacked or
their idea of islam not having one in
islam in reality islam was perfect
and they might just have to let it go
yeah let me let me slide something in
here too
all right because
people
they they're getting this guidance or
getting this wisdom is inside whatever
it is
but you gotta remember like what's
what's the main purpose here
right what's up what's our main purpose
as human beings
like it's very clear to worship allah
subhanahu wa allah
right we have to focus on the ahira not
the dunya either dunya this is temporary
we know this is temporary so if you know
that the main priority
is to set ourselves up
for the hero not for the dunya for the
akira
well then
you have to now look at these
things outside of islam they're not
setting you up for the hakida they're
setting you up for the dunya
they're setting you up to be good here
right now
but it's like yeah it might like like
brother musa was saying like it might
feel good right now
you might feel empowered right now
but you get to the point where it's like
you just get lost you get lost in the
sauce you get lost in in what it's
giving you which is
done your benefit
there's no accurate benefit there
yeah um
see we have a we have a comment here i
want to get brother musa's thoughts on
this so brother malik right this is why
men come in suicide on average five
times more than women to be an
emotionless man has nothing to do with
manhood it's the reason weak men always
go to aggression as they go to emotion
they believe it's masculine when it's
actually a weakness holding back growth
as a man so what are your thoughts on
that
and this is exactly why when we're
discussing this
feminism
how does feminism see you as a woman
what is how what does it think a woman
should be like red pill specifically red
red pill how does it value a man
what is seen as a high value man to red
pill
is not what islam sees as a high value
man and this is where people need to
realize
that
it's about
which way of life you're choosing
which way of life you're choosing
which deen you're choosing if you're
choosing islam as a deen okay as a way
of life then you need to look at the way
and who else if you're especially if
you're a muslim if you're a muslim
what does muslim mean a muslim is the
one who submits
to allah subhanahu ta'ala islam is
submission submission to who to whom to
allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala so subhanallah
allah s
submission enter into complete
submission
allah is telling you to completely
submit yourself to islam
and don't follow the footsteps of
shaytan in
indeed he is to you
a clear enemy my dear brothers and
sisters
if you speak to some of the people of
knowledge
about
the some of the biggest threats to
muslims today
they won't mention to you atheism they
won't mention to you
you know other religions they'll mention
to you
ideologies
ideally
because you see these ideologies to
muslims um the muslim he won't become an
atheist because he knows he can't be a
muslim and an atheist you won't become a
christian but here's where muslims fool
themselves they think i can be someone
who identifies by red people and be a
muslim
i can be someone who's a feminist muslim
right
and they don't understand that actually
there's something called shirk
we all know what shirk is associating
partners with allah but you can
associate partners with allah in
different angles in rubya in his
lordship okay you can associate partners
with allah in worship okay of course but
there's also
associating partners with allah in whom
you obey
so we as muslims are to be allah obey
allah but you you're obeying an ideology
an ideology is telling you this is right
this is right don't marry divorced women
do this
and you you're like you know what that
makes sense yeah i'm gonna follow that
and you don't realize but you may even
even at times be falling into shirk so
the point is
about the brother is saying you know
what does islam consider as a man
what's a man to islam now
some of these guys if you were to
describe the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam to them what do you think
they're going to say about the prophet
sallallahu alaihi some of these same
non-muslim
red pillars right these guys who
identified by red pill if you were to
say there's a man he lived in 7th
century arabia um you know he was not
the most wealthiest of men he lived a
very very simple life you know sometimes
you know um
there was there was no fire in the house
etc um you know and he was doing this
and he was in and he would spend a lot
of time
this is not what day class is a high
value man my brothers and sisters
all right to them this stuff is uh
it's like you know what i mean i'm not
going to say anything like what i'm
saying so it shows you islam
sees a high value man
men of value in a different way you know
muslim you know you can see like the
fear if you want to say or like the um
the humanness of musa
[Music]
how he mentions that you know you know
yes
that oh my lord i killed from amongst
them a person okay because he
accidentally killed someone okay
i killed from amongst them a person
so for a half of the world is actually
used
i'm scared that they're going to kill me
he's a man he's a man musa is a man
um
people who say about him he's known for
his manhood and what they think is
manhood yeah
but um
he was also known
you know to for the marks on his face
because of how much he used to cry he
used to weep
a man is someone who stands before allah
he cries
he hears the quran he cries
right you know business
are selling etc
these things do not divert them from the
remembrance of allah
and then you have read people saying
listen mate you need to do business you
need to get into this you need to you
need to up your and that's not we're not
saying we're against business we're not
saying we're against making money but
we're saying
the way these two ideologies because
islam if you want to quote islam is a
way of life sadeen the way these two
deens
look at a man is different
not a man a certain way and whether you
like it or not this is fact islam looks
at a man a certain way red pill looks at
a man a certain way which one do you
want to which which which definition do
you want to follow it's up to you some
definition made by a group of uh
yeah a group of guys who who they they
themselves are prone to mistakes or
something that we know is from allah
subhanallah bro that i love that point
bro we're gonna make a clip out of that
too because it was such a valuable point
but you you look at islam too what
defines you as a high value man in the
eyes of allah it's actually not
that difficult bro i didn't say it's
easy but it's simple right and you can
become that you can become in a very
short amount of time but when you look
at red pill right all the things it says
to become a good man
it's it's pretty inaccessible role to a
lot of people like you must have a lot
of wealth you must be this you must be
that like
like you jump through all these hoops
bro just to please an ideology not even
the creator but when you look at islam
allah is already telling us what to do
we already have the blueprint out for us
bro and it's not that difficult bro so
subhanallah brother hamza writes
see there's a reason why allah included
the stories of the prophets in the quran
so they can be a role models that's true
feminism and red pill are fundamentally
motivated by greed it's entitlement
disguised as equality
and then brother maliki writes the
standard of manhood is the prophet and
he wasn't
he
the standard of what a woman is
and she wasn't a feminist that's fox
yeah yeah and red pill is a response to
the extremism of feminism right
um it's a response to the extremism
feminism so like
look
all we need to realize is
just like in a marriage
if in a marriage if you go into a
marriage
and
and look at how this is making society
subhan allah
look at this now brothers and sisters
brothers yeah i want to ask you a
question
um the guys from red pill
they they believe red pill is best for
men right
okay
um feminists they believe feminism is
best for women right
okay
so let's let's let's put this scenario
into actuality all men become red
pillars and all women become feminists
what's good what's gonna happen
there's a divide the family unit is gone
okay
[Music]
[Laughter]
do you know what i'm saying now you know
what i just realized bro as soon as you
said that most of the men i've seen that
are red pilled they're with women that
are not feminists and most of the women
i know that are feminists their man is
not red-pilled yeah so
you asked what would happen if men
resorted to their own extreme and women
resorted to theirs respectively
yeah and i was right bro there would be
a divide there would be no congruency
within the man and woman dynamic no
family stability whatsoever because kid
would have a single or a two-parent
household
it's ridiculous bro both of these
ideologies and pay attention her
brothers and sisters both of these
ideologies are relying upon the opposite
sex to not follow the opposite ideology
they are both relying on the opposite
sex so for example men who are red pill
they are relying upon the opposite sex
not to be feminists
because if they were feminists it
wouldn't work and feminists are relying
relying upon men to not be red pill so
brothers and sisters
now let's put the islamic
let's put and this is how you know
by the way there's many reasons why
islam is from allah and by the way one
of the things that we go back to here
actually is you as a muslim work on your
yakin seek more knowledge and increase
yourself in certainty that islam is from
allah that is the truth
because when you do that as well you're
going to be even more happy if you are
certain about islam you're going to be
like listen i believe in everything that
islam says i don't even need to know
everything because i know it's from
allah
but check this out now
let's put islam into actuality now we
put red power and feminism into
actuality islam
the way islam encourages a lady to be
and the way encourage islam encourages a
man to be it creates a perfect
harmonious marriage a relationship
okay that it that it it connects like
this it fits together
and it
facilitates for a healthy society
a society without
men abusing women and women abusing men
a society that is harmonious and
futuristic
okay this is
what islam promotes if a muslim was to
actually follow islam in her actions and
a muslim man was to follow islam in his
actions in the way he has to be as a man
you will see harmony in society you will
see harmony in society
and that's that's when we realize when
we actually make these ideologies
practical we see they don't work they
actually don't work
they don't um take society forward they
take society backwards
[Music]
that's true
it's true very selfish ideologies very
selfish
based on the fact that you as a man you
have desires uh based on a on the fact
that you as a woman you don't like the
way um certain uh you know certain
things have happened etc very very very
selfish ideologies you know based on the
self
you know what's crazy too
is that when someone follows one of
these ideologies
and let's say they they hit the pinnacle
like they reach the top of the top of
like what this ideology is uh portraying
yeah
they're empty
yeah
yeah
yeah like you got you got the reptile
and you say oh you gotta have the status
you gotta have the looks you gotta have
the money you gotta have the women you
gotta have the women in rotation you
can't just have one woman and then
multiple can't be married
and then once you have it all it's like
uh
it's bro it's like this um i forgot who
said it was one
please if one of y'all know like chime
in but i think it was like a shake or
something who was holding up like a dead
piece of goat
and then he was like oh you want this
like you want this and then i was like
no no i don't want that i don't want
that he's like this is the dunya this is
everything in the dunya it's the
equivalent of this dead piece of goat
i think it was like
dunya in the eyes of allah is less
valuable than this dead goat is to you
does that go carcasses to you
yeah and that's that's what it is that's
what it is it's like
red pill all these all these ideologies
are like holding up this
this dead piece of goat that at first
to you it looks like
it looks like gold
it looks like it's like oh this is it
but then like the more you get into it
and then when you finally get it in your
hand and then you you hold it up you're
like
oh damn like this this ain't gold
it's a dead piece of goat the hell did i
just do i just wasted x amount of years
and now i got this dead piece of gold in
my hand this isn't gonna do anything for
me this isn't making me happy
and yeah man when there's fundamental
differences like that
and there are fundamental differences
between islam and these ideologies
you know and and this is guys this is
why so dangerous for the youth
it's so dangerous because
these things by some muslim brothers and
sisters aren't even seen as threatening
they aren't seen as dangerous
you know when your enemy is in front of
you and he's an enemy
khalas you know he's an enemy
but when your friend is an enemy
and he's got a knife to your back but
you don't even know it
someone you perceive as a friend someone
you perceive something you perceive as
so good for you
right and you're consuming it daily
you're like yeah this is good you know
and you're watching these guys and
you're like yeah this is how i need to
be as a man and whatever and it's
exactly what angel said because brothers
and sisters in in reality a lot of a lot
of the guys were probably getting into
this is because they feel a void
a lot of the sisters who get into you
know feminism you know it's probably
because they feel a void right
but we need to realize
that the void you know
you know
it is by the remembrance of allah
hearts find rest it's not about money
it's not about um you know how many
women you have
it's not about all of these things it's
about
your relationship with allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala if your relationship with
allah is good
everything
will be good the prophet salallahu he
told us that
that
in the fil
in the
human being's body there is a mudra
there is a piece of flesh either
if that piece of flesh is pure
if it's good
all of that human being is going to be
pure either that
says said if it's messed up
that
that piece of fluffy flesh if it's
messed up the whole body is going to be
mashed up
it is the heart
the human heart
it is the heart and
i'm sorry
these people who you're looking up to
their hearts are not in the right places
may allah guide them but their hearts
are not in the right places
so you know
thing
it's not it's not where it's at man it's
not where it's at
the happiest people i know personally
are those who are the closest to allah
they're the happiest people
that's [ __ ] and honor bro me and you
we can speak from experience bro the
deeper we go on this journey the more
fulfilled we feel with life
100 right
and you know there's a saying you know
why do you think in ramadan you feel so
good it's because our war of the months
in the year this is the one month that
you're actually
living for your purpose
you know ramadan why do you feel so good
why why is there even people on twitter
instagram they all talking about ramadan
oh ramadan
you guys you don't realize the reason
why you feel like that in ramadan is
because finally you're actually doing
what your purpose is
you're actually doing what your purpose
is your heart is actually in the right
place your heart is actually
cured
you know subhanallah and
this is the thing man it's like guys you
know if if you put
you know if you're putting diesel in an
unleaded car in a petrol car
you're gonna mash that car up
you're putting things in the wrong place
you need to put petrol in that car your
heart you're trying to fix your heart
with women with money with
you know temporary uh desires temporary
pleasure
you're gonna mash yourself up even worse
angel you know i know you you know a lot
of the videos you used to make uh on you
know people stopping pornography even
when you were a non-muslim the videos
you would make on people stopping
pornography and you know stopping that
stuff and whatnot and even even as a
non-muslim you know you i'm sure you
realize that
it's not about these temporary
when you're engaging in these temporary
pleasures you're actually delaying your
happiness and you're actually making
your happiness worse because you're
temporarily getting better but in terms
of long term you're actually getting
worse
you are
you definitely are
man and
what you said about ramadan is so true
like we experience the sweetness
of actually being a muslim
you know the rest of the year
we could we perhaps we might experience
it for the most part we're kind of
caught up in the dunya in every everyday
life
but when ramadan hits it's like
nah there's no distraction like
this is your true purpose
and if you if you you know
hit everything on point you're actually
making time for allah during ramadan you
experience that sweetness
you experience the sweetness from the
ibadah from the worship
and i think this is why it's so
important
for us as muslims
to fast outside of ramadan yeah yeah
you know like
personally
i started fasting uh mondays and
thursdays
because this brother you know may allah
bless him because he's the one that like
brought this on
uh but it was more so
just to control sexual urges
but the more that i i fast outside
ramadan the more i'm seeing like
wow it's a reset i only use a reset for
like my health and all that but in terms
of spirituality like
throughout the week i feel like i'm
slowly just like inching away from allah
like
just getting distracted with all these
things and then like once mondays and
thursdays come
like man it's it's a whole nother world
like the prayers
are just completely different like fully
fully into the prayer
my mind's not even like distracted or
anything like that
the time after the prayers is just
so reflective
and it's like it's like that sweetness
comes back
and like
man if if every single muslim were to be
fasting mondays and thursdays
i don't know
i i really allah knows best but i feel
like that would keep that sweetness
alive you know keep keep the taqwa alive
and keep
muslims more
more muslim
for like a better word
you know this stuff is life-changing bro
and
you know the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
he wanted guidance for us
as his ummah he wanted guidance for us
he wanted islam for us
allah in the quran in the beginning of
the surah it's called the translation of
called the poets
surah
you will destroy yourself out of grief
that these people are not becoming
believers
perhaps you will destroy yourself
you you you you will destroy yourself
out of grief
that these people
they are not becoming believers
you know
subhanallah the prophet sallam he cared
about
his people becoming muslims
so much becoming believers so much why
because he knows what this life is about
he knows what the ashira is about he
knows what it's about so when you're
distracting yourself with all of this
other stuff
this is not what life is about you know
whenever you go to people's funerals
the people
they always mention
so and so
he built this masjid so and so he was a
very charitable man so and so used to
pray a lot so and so memorize the quran
so and so and you know it's a
commonality within all of these things
they only mention things to do with the
religion and things to do with sadaka
and stuff these are like the only things
that are mentioned because even the
people who are still in this dunya who
had that funeral
even they realize
yeah no one cares that he was a
millionaire now
no one cares about how how many women he
had no one cares
about
how
high value of a man he was in society no
one gives a damn
now he's being referred to as the body
where should we move the body when
should we bury the body we're not even
calling him by his name now
and the only thing that they will care
to mention
is
oh yeah 15 years ago he uh built a
masjid for the village in
this country
they they're trying to find something
good to mention about him
because brother and sisters the reality
is
this life is not it one guarantee we all
have is we're gonna die and an
existential you know question that has
wanted many people for years
is
yo what the heck is gonna happen to me
after i've gone
what i'm gonna die what happens after
death
philosophers are talking about it
everyone is talking about we as muslims
we know subhanallah we know you know
allah says
allah speaks about how in the throat
when the soul it reaches this this area
and you all you can see
right
and we are closer to him
than you
but you can't see
but you can't see
but
allah is essentially saying if you
basically think this stuff is fake
right essentially right you see
that soul
bring it back
bring it back that's all you've just
seen bring it back you're not going to
be able to bring it back
and this is these are signs in front of
us what's going on around us guys people
are losing their lives and subhanallah
there's a story from the israeli
okay so the authenticity of it is
questionable et cetera may be
questionable but
we can learn a lesson from him
a man he spoke to the angel of death
and he said to the angel of death
essentially and of course i paraphrased
the whole thing i see what you're doing
with people i see what you're doing with
people you're just taking these people's
souls
right
with me i want to have an agreement with
you when you take my soul
i want you to let me know before you do
okay instead of disagrees with him
okay
so
he's living his life he goes on etc and
then the angel of death later on in his
life comes to take his life
and he said we had an agreement
angela said death says i let you know
how did you let me know
you know so and so uncle that you have
he passed away last year i took his soul
so-and-so grandfather that you have i
took his soul
around you all of the people around you
i took their souls one by one and now
you left
now it's you left
these these are signs for us
so
why we become so emotional when we hear
about death and we hear about these
topics etc and we become serious and it
affects us it's because wallahi we know
this is the reality
we we know this is the reality we're
gonna go we're gonna go
and guys no one cares
kevin samuels
okay and i'm not mentioning it to
disrespect anyone but he passed away i
don't know like a week ago a week ago a
week exactly from now
a week literally last friday he passed
away
as soon as he passes away people saying
bad things about him etc now who's
talking about him
not many
not many and in a year who's gonna
remember this person
and i'm mentioning this as a sign as a
thing guys
it's not about life is not about this
this is what not not not what life is
about
life
is about
you know
that day wealth these things that we
value wealth
and manual and children
that day now it's not going to benefit
you
the only thing that's going to benefit
you on that day
is this heart that you came with
as long as it was a good heart if it was
a good heart that's gonna benefit you if
you mashed up your heart
if you've done the wrong things if you
were addicted to pornography if you were
you know doing haram if you are going
against
you know you are wronging yourself
and even non-muslims when they do these
sins
when they drink alcohol they take drugs
they watch pornography they sleep around
and commit zina they feel an emptiness
this emptiness they are feeling it is
alarm bells
they they are letting themselves know
i'm not they themselves they don't know
about the revelation maybe about islam
etc but their body they themselves their
nafs is letting them know you got yo
listen man the way you're living your
life
this is not it
this is not it
this this is this is not it
you
why are you feeling and technically you
shouldn't be feeling like that logically
why are you feeling like that you're
fulfilling your desires why should you
be feeling like that
logically
look but it doesn't work like this
there's logics there are logics that
these people don't have
and that is the logic of islam the way
allah looks at things the way allah
looks at things subhanallah these these
non-muslims they come and they say
uh you know you're relative he uh he's
going to pass away in six months you
know maybe we should take him off life
support machine maybe we should do this
maybe we should do that they don't look
at things the way that we do that when
we go through problems we see it as
hadith mentioned
even if a thorn pricks are muslim
his sins are expiated from that non
muslims don't care like that
they look at these things as problems
tells us
said this allah afflicts that person
with trials
if allah is good for you he's going to
test you you're going to be tested
do the people think to the people
perceive
that they're going to be left alone
you know
and to say we believe i believe and then
they're not going to be tested
they're not going to be tested it's not
like that you're going to be tested this
life is a test angel you rightly
mentioned earlier this life our purpose
of life is is to worship allah okay but
also this life is a test
he created death and life
just
so so brothers and sisters we know all
of these things
and uh this is a reminder to myself
first man
wasn't it he created uh life and death
to see which of us
was best in um
actually yeah yeah
yeah
[Music]
so
we we had our own relationships bro in
the title but i don't think we got time
for that today inshallah next time
there's there's a lot to unpack from
here but you know there's two more uh
you know thing number chats that i want
to address so brother always writes
yesterday i wasn't feeling well i almost
felt like death was coming
when you realize the truth that death is
just coming more and more closer you
don't think about this dunya anymore
there's this
i mean this is one thing i read in this
book
by imam al-ghazali and he was mentioning
that this guy he was saying this song
like story
and he said that
this life is like a dream
and death is like
this curtain that's unveiled
so once you die it's like you wake up
and then this like curtain is lifted up
and now it's like now you're in reality
so it's like
it's basically just you know saying the
same thing i just thought it was very
fitting to throw in there
[Music]
um 5106 writes everyone pressures the
dunya on you when you're alive yet only
judge you on your when you're dead
yeah
yeah
this this is why it's so important
to put allah first
yeah
and stay on dean do what you got to do
to stay on being like be a prophet
muslim and in order to be a proper
muslim you have to follow the correct
belief system
the you have to have the correct akita
and then
you also have to put your ego aside
like how could you be a muslim if you
have an ego
you know like yeah i'm not saying like
oh i don't have an ego i haven't even
i'm not gonna lie to you
but when your ego is in control like
yeah you're not submitting
you're really not submitting you you're
acting out of arrogance and and you're
humbled you know at some point or
another allah will humble you and you
will learn from it it's like you you'll
snap out of it but like when you are in
this humble state when you put your ego
aside you feel the sweetness
of islam bro you feel the sweetness of
the bother that you do and it all just
connects it all makes sense
that's something i was trying to get at
but i completely forgot y'all you know
on that point angelia there's a teeth
where the prophet sallallahu sallam he
said
that the prophet told us
that whoever
he gives greatness to himself he thinks
that he himself is great
and when he walks on the earth when he
walks he walks in a prideful manner that
person is going to meet allah on the day
of judgment and allah will be angry with
that person
so so it shows you like all of this
thing where you're being promoted to be
this arrogant
uh person who walks on the earth like
you've made it etc
this is not what it's about it's an and
and we look at the opposite the prophet
saw he expressed to us
whoever
humbles himself before allah subhanahu
wa
he humbles himself for allah
the hadith mentions
for allah he's not humbling himself for
the people he's humbling himself for
allah he's being humble for allah allah
will raise that person
that person allah will raise him
you're going to see him being raised
so
this is this is what it is guys choices
need to be made
and instead of focusing and watching and
focusing on trying to you know become
this and become that
you know
believe me the person who makes the
akira their number one objective
their number one priority to fix their
akhirah allah will look after that
person
[Music]
you take care of the rulings related to
allah
as the hadith mentions you basically you
know preserve allah preserve the rights
of allah allah will preserve you
simply
he said that you know when human beings
were faced with two choices one to
please allah and kind of get disapproval
of the dunya kind of get that formal
feeling or to put to to be validated and
you know do things that are going to get
approval from other people but you get
disapproval from allah too many times
wrote too often times people will pick
the bad option bro the one where you you
seek the validation of other people at
the expense of of allah bro and that's
the thing like peer pressure is a real
thing bro today nobody wants to feel
left out bro there's hadith the prophet
saw mentioned that islam began as
something strange and indeed we'll
return to something strange so glad
tiding to the strangers and today we
need to realize and this is a message to
myself first and foremost that
even though no one's with you bro if you
were the last muslim alive today would
you really be muslim ask yourself that
question bro and inshallah can and can
you know guide us to a point where we
can undoubtedly grow with with without a
shadow of a doubt bro say yes because
too many people they'll they'll walk
they'll talk the talk bro but when it's
time to walk the walk they won't do it
bro when no one else is praying they
don't want to pray because they're like
oh i don't want to act awkward and i
don't want to go pray and they're going
to think i'm like you know i'm like a
sheikh or something bro at the end of
the day huck is huck bro there's no
denying it
100 man 100
and imagine imagine allah is watching
you allah is watching you saying i don't
want to be religious
allah is watching you saying that allah
is you know allah see you you know and
this is the reality man and you know and
and you know what we were supposed to
speak about haram relationships and all
of this other stuff but the reality is
guys you know if if the people are
clever and i'm sure they are and they
understand from our words when we're
talking about the ashira and becoming a
better person etc
they will understand
if you understand this
you understand everything you understand
everything
you know
so i don't know
i need to get going it is time for a
juma
yeah bro we got a drummer as well bro i
was gonna say let's just wrap it up no
so you guys are like seven hours behind
or something what time is it five hours
five hours from the uk
okay it's uh it's one nineteen nineteen
and i got like 15 minutes to get dressed
to make wudu and head over to the masjid
[Music]
one more time inshallah next time we can
talk about all the other stuff that we
wanted to talk about uh and until then
bro i'll just keep you in my duals and
uh do you have any closing remarks bro
before we wrap it up
may allah bless you all please keep us
in your eyes and forgive us for any
mistakes as well
i mean i mean i mean all right guys
was